so a few years ago I had to make a work
trip to Stockholm um because it was the
school holidays I needed to take my two
kids along with me and at the time they
were 14 and
12 anyway the my local colleagues you
needless needless to say were really
very supportive and in fact knowing that
I do research on language and social
class that also clearly enjoyed
arranging to put us into a hotel
belonging by a large sweet chain called
Elite
hotels so on the day that we arrived we
checked in and then we made our way
straight up to our room but as soon as
we crossed the threshold my oldest son
declared with genuine frustration but
this isn't
aite and I was a little bit surprised
but also kind of really curious to know
exactly what he meant so I sort of
pressed him and he quickly explained to
me that the room was just not big enough
to be elite
so in that moment I realized that my son
had already learned two really important
lessons about everyday language first
that words are very influential but
their meaning can often be
slippery and second that the language of
superiority and comparison can lead to
disappointment but it's
tough nowadays we're bombarded with
messages about Excellence dis
distinction and success and we hear
voices telling us you should be a top
student or a winner or a leader or
preferably all
three and it's this that's started me to
think a little bit more about what's
going on here how do we how do we manage
this because all of this leads to a
profound sense of what the philosopher
aland de baton has called status anxiety
and for me this is a kind of anxiety
that arises through our constant worry
about not being good enough or always
needing to be someone better or to have
something better but the reality is
this not everyone can be a top student
not everyone can be a winner and not
everyone can be a leader by the simple
law of averages most of us have to live
a life more
ordinary well it's for this reason that
I've started to rethink or perhaps even
reclaim the notion of mediocrity yeah
and I've even been challenging myself to
consider the possibility of embracing
mediocrity now obviously I understand
that mediocrity has a bad reputation
right with sort of connotations like
average quality or not very good yeah
but the sociol linguist in me insists on
digging just a little bit deeper maybe
listening to some of the word's Origins
and unearthing some of its other meaning
Potentials in actual fact the word
mediocre has its roots in the Indo
European medial meaning
middle so essentially then mediocrity is
just about existing between two extremes
hence middling or average or otherwise
unexceptional or
ordinary so as I say statistically
speaking life in the middle is
inevitable and unavoidable for most of
us and in fact it seems to me that the
middle is not such a terrible place to
be in fact it's quite a privileged place
to be it may not be as good as being at
the top but it's surely not as bad as
being at the
bottom and the trick I suppose is to
learn to recognize our mediocrity or at
least our averageness or our
ordinariness without allowing other
people to make us feel like failures or
losers needless to say this is quite a
bit harder to say harder to do than it
is to say and I think especially so
nowadays when we surrounded by these
voices pressuring us to be the best and
to be better we find ourselves I think
in a world um that is bombarded or con
confronted constantly with what I've
come to think of as a Relentless
language of superiority and comparison
and it's as a sociol linguist that I've
been tracking this language for quite
some time and in this work what I've
been trying to do is show that this is
not just a Relentless language but it's
also often a very sneaky surreptitious
language and it's with this in mind that
I want to just share with you a couple
of my favorite examples of what this
looks like like these are my two
favorite case studies and the first of
these is the word elite
itself and this is a word that
circulates everywhere in our lives which
is as my son discovered in Stockholm but
take a look at a few of the many
examples that I've also been
collecting so here we have an elite
grocery store in Denmark we have elite
nail salon in Seattle we've got an an
elite phone shop in the UK an elite
electricians in Switzerland actually in
burn and then an elite pastry shop or
Bakery in Poland and all of these I can
assure you appear in decidedly non-
Elite spaces
yeah but when I say that Elite crops up
everywhere I mean really
[Music]
everywhere I promise that after this
talk you are going to start noticing
Elite everywhere
too and I've never been quite sure what
we're supposed to think when we're being
told that our pickles are Elite or our
tissues yeah what exactly I wonder does
an elite condom
offer and I don't know about you but
it's going to take a lot more than the
word elite to convince me that a urinal
is in any way
prestigious but the use of the word
elite like this is a very very common
language game nowadays we see this word
attached to all sorts of goods and
services kind of meaning everything and
nothing at the same
time and in some ways I suppose it's all
perfectly harmless a bit playful even
but I can't help but think and in fact I
genuinely believe that these ubiquitous
constant appeals to eliteness are trying
to persuade us that superiority really
does matter and that status is something
that we should be thinking about all the
time and these little one-word messages
also suggests to us that superiority is
easily
obtained to be very clear the the
language of superiority and comparison
is really good for
business all of these Relentless little
one-word messages and ones like them are
trying to keep us aspiring upwards all
the time and if we're aspiring we're
also acquiring in other words we're
shopping
and for this they don't even need us
aspiring to be the best just aspiring to
be better is often enough which brings
me to my second little case study the
one little onew message that I'm talking
about in this instance is premium and a
good example of this appears in the
so-called premium economy services
offered by most major International
Airlines nowadays and it's no
coincidence that premium economy can be
more profitable for Airlines than
business
class but what's interesting about this
little one-word message is that it's
precisely not about being the best
premium is all about having just a
little bit extra or a little bit more
and especially a little bit extra or a
little bit more compared with
others
MH and to be sure marketers know only
too well that people will pay good money
for feeling better off even that is when
this comparison doesn't make us feel
very good for very long
yeah but the most striking thing about
the word premium is that it really crops
up in way more banile spaces and I'm
offering you a few more examples than
before because I really want to impress
upon you just how far-reaching this
one-word message is so we have premium
chocolates in Sweden not Switzerland we
have premium chips in Spain premium
coffee in Australia premium tomatoes in
New Zealand and burgers in Denmark what
we seem to have in Switzerland are
premium cigarettes and premium barbecue
charcoal elsewhere we've got premium
puzzles premium haircuts and my most
recent encounter in Poland premium baby
diapers again premium is just about
having a little bit more or a little bit
extra compared with others and as I say
these comparisons are usually built on
Illusions and these comparisons just
don't make us feel good for very
long in fact all of these silly little
language games are a perfect example of
what the famous sociologist Pier bourier
called symbolic
violence and in a nutshell this is about
the way that we allow words to
manipulate us even when it's against our
own best interests so while social
comparison May indeed be in our nature
it invariably leaves us feeling insecure
inadequate unsatisfied there will always
be something more or something better
and there will always be
someone better and better
off so the question for me is this how
can we avoid doing symbolic violence to
ourselves well personally I find myself
returning once again to the possibility
that mediocrity might hold the key or a
key now I understand that embracing
mediocrity might feel just a little bit
extreme or uncomfortable for some people
which I think is fair enough but the
point is really just about coming to
terms with the inevitability of our
averageness and maybe coming to find
finding a way to find the value and
perhaps the privilege in being
unexceptional and for this we've got to
keep reminding ourselves that it really
is okay not to be the best and it's
certainly okay not to always want to be
someone better or to have something
better but I think that
nowadays especially when we are
surrounded by this Relentless language
of superiority comparison it takes
determination and it also takes real
courage to be ordinary thank
you